il fait le déplacement de Paris vers
Bruxelles avec son hôte d'hier soir donc
c'est dans l'avion présidentiel que le
trajet s'effectue il a couplé Bruxelles
ce matin tôt pour une arrivée au
Parlement européen où il doit rencontrer
d'abord la présidence Roberta metzella
et puis pendant une demi-heure à peu
près s'adresser aux députés européens
réunis en session plénière
extraordinaire dans l'hémicycle
bruxellois ils sont venus à Bruxelles
spécialement ce n'était pas une semaine
de session parlementaire ni une semaine
de commission parlementaire et puis par
la suite voilà diverselenski se rendra
quelques centaines de mètres de là dans
le bâtiment du Conseil de l'Union
européenne du Conseil européen plutôt il
va évidemment à nouveau marteler la
demande qu'il a déjà largement évoqué
hier soir à Paris hier matin à Londres
savoir
demande d'avion de combat l'avion de
chasse de chasseurs bombardiers
multiro en général les Ukrainiens ont
toujours poussé pour cette demande
depuis que la demande des chars léopards
a été finalement accepté on connaît la
tactique des Ukrainiens qui consiste à
demander beaucoup tout de suite et très
vite et ça finit toujours par marcher
puisque les Européens avaient
généralement relativement exclu même la
livraison d'armes défensives au départ
et puis finalement ils livrent des
Panzer donc il y a de fortes chances que
les demandes de voldemoiselle esqui
soient
accepté un jour en tout cas pour les
Européens c'est surtout des munitions
qu'il faut fournir à l'Ukraine
maintenant
sur le terrain